so since I've seen I've seen you and
you're just thinking about that as as
you walk by I haven't seen you by the
way you look great I thank you I didn't
know you'd lost all this weight I
haven't seen you in a while yes maybe
the Dice Clay years and that's got to be
2004 maybe so since we did the gate
together yeah I didn't know we were in
Vegas together and you and Jim had
opened up for him multiple times prior
to me doing it so I didn't know the
whole dice thing of it you go to the
mall oh you had to do the whole thing
your shopping yeah you know dice this is
gonna be great go to nightclubs and he's
like no we're gonna go shop for couches
yeah it's very disappointing and then he
make you buy like XL hoodies to match
his he's got the weirdest idea of
friendship he's such an odd guy I love
him and he changed my life but you how
long did you tour with him for two years
and yeah we would do this excel like we
would go to harley-davidson that would
be a spot and he just go on you know
take it the pro deal that's right the
pro do you remember the Broadway
certainly do nice we just go in there
and steal ten million dollars he's just
stealing [ __ ] hoodies so would you
just go in this door you put it on you
walk out I wouldn't yeah he's a funny
guy man he's a really fun dude then he
loves sweets
you're gonna candy store can't work out
then we go get a Slurpee the best
stories two of it that he goes into open
houses and just runs up and down the
steps and [ __ ] crazy this is what
happens when you don't drink you know I
mean like if you're not on the road
drinking what else are you gonna do
right
you got to find other [ __ ] make you
happy and make you feel good about ya
ridiculous [ __ ] yeah yeah but he would
do that he would you'd work out and this
is before I worked out and he was a
[ __ ] Kenny or happy face and they
would have to have a giant Starbucks
that with the whipped cream and the
actually mocha chips he was [ __ ]
extra mocha you really draining and he
had this giant chocolate treat
afterwards but any calories he burned
working me out he would just immediately
get the back and add you can't work out
have a [ __ ] 1800 calorie beverage but
he was a fun guy man and you learned the
crowd had they treated the audiences I
was a decent success with them yeah it
was tough it was one of those things
where I got actually thrown off a little
bit where I ended my set early and I
came off and he he wasn't happy at all
he's like what are you doing you know no
matter how bad it's going you finish
your time so you know I mean it was like
why didn't they like you he wasn't dice
out there and it was a hostile crowd
they wanted to see him and it threw my
act off and timing off and I got off a
little bit early and he set me straight
which you know I like you said it
learned a lot you know working with him
and his crowds and and torn with him so
yeah it was a great experience I don't
know I grew up watching dice so he was
always theatrical and his dress yeah new
leather coat every special yes special
hmm I think that the best dice leather
coat was the MTV Music Awards with the
with the the black and white zebra yeah
[ __ ] something I was like a rug in
Scarface he really was he was he warrant
without shame and comfortably and it
just worked